screen
i assume people can
see my screen okay
great okay
well good um
i want to welcome everyone to
the first um
research conference for the new academic
year
i
apologize that i was not able to
attend the orientation last week i
actually have a slide about what i was
doing you'll see it has a different
context but
i was actually in germany last week
uh but anyways as kind of has been the
tradition
for the um
last number of years i uh usually kick
off the
research conference
we're now entering our
um
second year of um
i guess technically third year if you
count the latter half of two years ago
uh
um as as this conference being virtual
and it's probably going to be virtual
for
some uh period of time
um that said i will um
go ahead and
uh give you my talk i i trying to spend
less than the full hour i um we'll leave
some time at the end if people want to
uh chime in on anything that i have said
or omitted
so as i typically do i i will talk a
little bit about the state of the
program uh talking about the department
the uh research education and faculty
um and then i'll make a few comments
about the state of the field obviously
um i i can't cover everything but just
uh some of the highlights on some of the
things i think are important
and then again i'll leave some time at
the end for others to chime in or ask
questions
so
um as you all know we are the department
of medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology
uh an academic department in the school
of medicine
uh focused on three areas
uh bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine clinical epidemiology and
health and clinical informatics we carry
out our mission through programs of
research education and service
and
we are very well known
around the world at least in the
informatics field for the work that we
do
and we have a website which has that
nice vanity url
and we also have a blog which uh anyone
is welcome to
um i come up with ideas to publish about
so it has been a challenging year and a
half
for the department for the university
for the world
we
have made a
i think we've demonstrated over the last
18 months that we can pretty much
function as a virtual organization
although i i think many of you like
myself um
would would love to be around others we
we were all set we had our plans for
returning to the office and then uh
delta came
and so we're continuing
to function remotely hopefully that
won't be forever
um one good bit of news even though
um
even though in informatics we work a lot
with technology but but we really are a
people field
and we focus on how technology can use
people can can benefit people especially
related to
health and health care and public health
and um fortunately for those of us who
have um
been around a while and have a lifetime
of friends and colleagues
and also have various tools now to keep
in touch with them so
and and i know that there are some
generational uh differences in how
social media is used but certainly i um
have fortunately been able to keep in
touch with a lot of good friends and
colleagues um mainly with facebook i
know that's kind of date maybe uh
placing me in a certain generation
but i use other social media tools as
well
but for the social side of it
for better or worse and i have my issues
with facebook the company but um it is a
nice tool to keep in touch with people
and another good bit of news is that um
actually the universities finances are
doing
pretty well the department um is doing
pretty well
um and so um we we move on and um but
again i uh personally i i hope that we
can start
um
interacting um in person again
so we'll see
so um just a little speaking of money um
certainly money is not the most
important thing when it comes to our
research but it is something by which
we're judged and
d mice has done particularly well over
the years you see um these the kind of
data points that people like department
chairs keep
um
interesting um aspect of this is you
look at our research funding which has
gradually increased over time and then
there's two spikes
which
correlate with when that correlate which
are
occurred during
global crises the the first big spike
was back in
around 2009 2010 during the great
recession
and and all the money that was poured
into health i.t
um and then the second spike a little
bit smaller of a one was uh last year um
in in particular a lot of the funding
that became available
in the early days the pandemic
um
but again money's not the only important
thing um we
do well with publications uh uh thanks
to catherine pyle for uh keeping track
of these things well
um and not only just publications but
publications in in top journals whether
it's top informatics journals or top
medical journals and it's mostly the
evidence-based practice center uh from
the clinical epidemiology group that
does a lot of systematic reviews that
are published in very high profile
journals
we actually have a pretty good success
rate of grant funding
the overall nih funding some of you may
be aware of is depending on the
institute is 10 to 20 percent um we we
do considerably considerably better than
that
um and our educational programs are are
very robust it's great for me to see a
lot of
students in this talk
you really are
an important part of what we do
i know that many of us many
hopefully all but certainly many of the
faculty are very
passionate about teaching
and
helping you
launch your careers in informatics
so
things like the national library
medicine training grant that's been
funded continuously since 1992 making it
the largest and second longest running
training grant at uni at ohsu
we also had the distinction of hosting
the first ever
virtual trainees meeting i've been
attending the nlm trainees meeting since
i was an nlm trainee in the late 1980s
um it's it's an important meeting to get
to know future colleagues
um the um i'm not sure that the virtual
format captures everything that
one can do in person but
nonetheless
trainees have been able to present their
work and interact with others
we have also had our graduate program
since 1996
that's when we launched our master's
degree program we launched our phd
program in 2003
we started teaching online courses in
1999
we um in partnership with amia our
professional association launched the
um 10 by 10 program which is an
adaptation of the biomedical informatics
510 course that i teach
were zeroing in probably sometime next
year on on 3 000 people
having completed the ohsu offering and
some of those people
use that course as a launching point
into their informatics studies
we've also
been the recipient of many educational
grants over the years um
part of that big spike back from around
2011
was the funding we received from the
office of national coordinator
and our work goes on i
just learned a couple weeks ago that a
new grant has been funded
with some colleagues from the university
of cape town
last year the nih announced the new
initiative called harnessing data
science for health discovery and
innovation in africa and i'm already
part of i'm on a scientific advisory
board of a project called health and
human heredity in africa
their bioinformatics network i know
many of you wonder bill bioinformatics
but i'm actually the clinical
informatics representative um on that
scientific advisory board and that
enabled us to
put put together this grant proposal and
so um some of our online clinical
informatics courses
probably starting next year
may see some students or should see some
students from the university of cape
town and possibly other
universities around africa
making the world a smaller place
we've also been involved with
medical students teaching medical
students
paul gorman vishnu mohan jeff gold um
gretchen scholl and others
um
our medical students at ohsu probably
get more clinical informatics than any
other medical school in the country
um we also have a um
we've also been active in the new uh
physician
uh clinical informatics sub-specialty
one of the first programs to receive
accreditation from the accreditation
council for graduate medical education i
see several of our clinical informatics
fellows
um here and and actually so we're not
only one of the first programs there are
actually uh several other fellowship
programs that use our online courses
which also creates nice
peer groups and so forth then
vishnu mohan has led that
and then we've also
been developing continuing education
we have heard from our alumni over the
years not just physicians wanting cme
credit but other alumni
wanting to continue to interact with us
and so we can continue to have
continuing education courses
um you've seen versions of this slide
and other talks that i've given um but
um we
have a
wide reach of our program with our
online program i mentioned africa a
moment ago
we have other international
collaborations and also uh
have many students from around the
country
you see the numbers there which that's
table was updated after
this past year's graduation
if you do get a chance to walk into our
office on the fifth floor of the book
this uh i just saw it the other day this
bookcase is still there behind diane's
desk that has actually this is just some
of the theses and dissertations that
have been done over the years there's
actually another
shelf worth of them so our students have
been very productive as well
um we also um have some highly
accomplished uh faculty some of this is
is uh
news that's almost hot off the press
um
many of you know peter mb
who was a postdoc
and also did our master's degree
completing the program back in 2002
we were excited a number of years ago
when he was appointed president ceo of
the regan street institute which is the
research um arm connected with indiana
university well as some of you who uh
maybe follow various social media
channels or or any email list know he uh
peter has just been appointed chair of
the department of biomedical informatics
at vanderbilt one of the very
prestigious programs uh in the country
um and in fact he will now be becoming
the boss of another highly accomplished
alumnus adam wright
who was our first phd graduate and he
set the bar very high
and
so adam has been
a professor in the department of
biomedical informatics at vanderbilt but
adam also
um has been awarded this um year the
donald a b lindbergh award for
innovation in informatics so we're very
uh proud of adam
um i i actually won that award um a year
after adam graduated um and so it's also
it's good to see another ohsu connection
uh we have many other accomplished
alumni i i can't really list them all
here um but i just wanted to show some
of the
um diverse interests um so some of you
know jay shree calpathy cramer
who um has very become very prominent in
the imaging informatics world um she is
at harvard medical school
and surendra dasari uh who works in
bioinformatics and is an associate
professor at the mayo clinic and then i
um
just threw in a recent graduate
adam rule who has just started his
position
at the university of wisconsin in the
information school as a tenure track
assistant professor and there's many
others it's always risky to make lists
of people
because you may leave people out so i
didn't want to leave out
the
members of our alumni who
are now members of our faculty and we
have a long lineage of faculty who are
graduates of our program
starting with paul gorman who did a
postdoc before we even had the nlm
funding or any degree program
um
followed on on the heels by um joan ash
who also we received news today that she
is going to be honored at the amia
meeting as a distinguished fellow of the
american college of medical informatics
which is
the um honorific
society that's part of amia
that
honors leaders in the field um
aaron cohen uh was the early well not so
early graduate of our program and joined
our faculty um eilish boudreau uh vishnu
steve mike lisa michelle
jamie um and then most recently um dana
womack who uh graduated with her phd and
actually did a little bit of postdoc
work and then joined the faculty um and
ben orwell who was the first um
graduate of our clinical informatics
fellowship to
uh join our faculty who has a joint
appointment with pediatrics i i
apologize if i left anyone out and if if
i did you can uh bring it up at the end
and um
make sure that um everyone
is announced
um it's also important to acknowledge
the current students in the program we
have currently 98 students who are
actively enrolled in the program
um
you see the numbers a little higher for
health and clinical informatics
reflecting our online um
well historically online i guess
everyone is online now
and um uh but all across the different
uh programs phd masters and graduate
certificate
um and i hope to interact with um all of
you
during the course of the year and the
course of your studies at ohsu
we we also have a very distinguished
faculty i i would argue among the most
accomplished informatics faculties
anywhere in the country or the world
again my slides only have a sampling you
can actually go to our website and get a
complete listing
and of course
as as much as we try to keep the website
up to date um
new people come along and and so we we
do our best
um we also have faculty who are in
institutional leadership roles david
door who's ohsu's chief research
information officer karen eden who just
completed a term as president of the
faculty senate
paul gorman involved in many medical
school
activities um shannon mcweeney who's the
director of computational biomedicine at
the night
uh vishnu mohan who's the program
director of our fellowship and cynthia
morris
who
is involved with
our clinical and translational research
institute um and also uh heads up the
large collaborative program with
portland state called build exeter which
aims to provide a pathway for
historically underrepresented
students to
pursue careers in in research not not
just becoming faculty and pi but careers
as research associates research
assistants and so forth
um so we really are a team in d mice and
um
you know as i've mentioned our faculty
have a broad array of interests and
accomplishments and um i will always put
in my plug for the faculty to present at
this conference so our own students can
hear about the great work that you do
um and sometimes we do two-for-ones
where we have two faculty uh present um
so they only have to have 30 minutes of
presentation
uh but hopefully we'll
get a lot of faculty on the list and and
um you know one of the
one of the silver linings of the
pandemic has been that we've actually
been able to have more
um
external speakers we we've had several
we had
over the summer we have william brown uh
sarah rossetti
um and
kendra cato among others and if anyone
has
someone they would like us to invite um
just drop me an email and um i would be
happy to invite them one of the
advantages of the virtual conference is
that they don't
have to leave their home of course
part of the fun of of being an invited
speaker is actually going to
speak at a particular location
we also have incredibly competent staff
in our department we have the
central departmental demise staff and
marshall our department administrator
megan alicia
catherine and monica
and then we also have staff um
related to the educational program led
by andrea but also diane lauren lynn
of virginia and kate
and then we have other uh
members around the department who
support individual faculty and projects
and of course we have students and
fellows who
will hopefully be presenting and
defending their work at this conference
also at the nlm trainees meeting and in
other venues
and making valuable contributions to the
activities of the department
i encourage people to
follow us on
social media probably our main
channel is twitter
and
somehow
there's someone
behind the curtain who's out there
tweeting
from oasisu informatics i don't know who
that is uh it's actually me um i'm in
addition to being department chair i'm
our social media chair
um and we also have a blog and if you
have something interesting you want to
write about something that you or your
group has accomplished let us know and
we'll work with you to get it posted and
of course then we will
disseminate it out there by our twitter
feed and other means
okay well that that's my kind of brief
overview of the department so let me
switch gears and talk a little bit about
the state of the field again um
i i'm just going to touch on some real
highlights here and i'll be um
interested to hear
um if others
want to add some additional things that
that are important but um
um i'll start by talking about the
some of the lessons learned from the
pandemic
but also note that the rest of the field
has not stood still
and other things have been happening and
i will talk about these four topics
again uh briefly
um
so i think we uh well we've learned a
lot of lessons about the world from the
pandemic we've also learned informatics
lessons and um it's clear
that especially
in the united states our public health
information infrastructure has not
really been up to the task
of um
giving us
up-to-date um
information about the pandemic
it's playing out right now unfortunately
the
cdc doesn't have the means to
track every breakthrough infection
and
associate that with vaccination status
things like that with
sequencing of the virus if it's the
delta variant which pretty much all all
cases are now
um and um there have been there's been a
lot written and and by the way um
um i will be pointing to some references
um
that you can get there's a pdf on my
webpage that has all of these uh
citations if you want to follow any of
them and also my slides um and of course
also um i sent out a tweet this morning
um with the url to the
to the pdf file
um we we've also um
not been able to uh
have a good clinical and clinical trials
infrastructure
to
evaluate different
therapies and to quickly dispense of
those that are of no benefit so
we should for example and we did do
studies of things like
hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin they
weren't up to the task and that should
be the end of it but unfortunately um
there's not a robust infrastructure to
keep track of all those trials and and
to pursue the promising new therapies
also somewhat related to my research
interests are
that we have learned that our both our
professional and our general information
channels are easily abused i'll talk
about that in the
next slide and then we've also learned
that our
inadequacies of our data of our
algorithms
exacerbate our health disparities and
impede our racial justice i'll talk
about that too
um there was a headline earlier this
week in the new york times um
something that's very well known about
the um
uptake the variable uptake
in different parts of the united states
which is associated with political views
red and blue
and that this has um also led to
disparities in
um
hospitalizations deaths uh and so forth
from covet
and um most of this
uh misinformation or disinformation has
come from um a particular side of the
political spectrum unfortunately
um it's unfortunate
that
covet has been politicized
it would be much better if it were not
and then we also have means to
in the in the old days there was there's
always been misinformation
disinformation around in the world
but in the old days it it mostly stayed
within small groups of people but we
have social media we have um
groups entities that know how to
um
use social media to vastly get out that
message that then competes with
um more
authoritative and correct
information
and um we also
uh there's an element of society that um
is is very anti-science um
uh pete uh professor peter hotez who
i actually don't follow a massive number
of people on twitter i just there's just
not enough hours in the day
however um
peter hotez is one that i do follow he's
the dean of tropical medicine at texas
children's hospital something like that
i may have gotten his title wrong but
he's written very eloquently about the
anti-science movement and the ideology
that drives it and the results are
seen
in this
screenshot of the front page of the new
york times from earlier in the week
which i actually
captured because another person i enjoy
following on twitter um is eric topple
who's also been very good about
um
describing annotating the the stream of
science
around coved
another interesting phenomenon that's
happened is that some of the um things
that we
have
we think are valuable in
science like open science with
pre-prints and things like that
which i i i think
i still think are very important but
clearly this uh system can be abused
so our publishing scientific publishing
system has been overwhelmed with
publications
and
some
some of them are
only have cursory peer reviews some of
them don't have peer review at all
some of them
get
retracted
when
things happen
but unfortunately once something has
gotten out there onto the internet
it may take on a life of its own and
this has historically been a problem but
it's just so exacerbated with the
pandemic
um and not only that you have a lot of
people who are doing systematic reviews
and so they're pulling in uh sometimes
these studies that were later retracted
or otherwise of low quality
and um
part of this is preprints uh preprints
are are a great phenomena i certainly
um have enjoyed being able to put my own
uh work up on on a preprint server as
it's being peer reviewed
so they speed dissemination information
good and bad and so
again just some recent examples from the
past
a few weeks um actually i guess this
that
one of the early ivermectin trials was
riddled with errors with plagiarism and
things like that yet it was the first
large clinical trial so it got a lot of
press
it never made it be on a pre-print
server um but the damage was done and
and actually the pre-print server that
it was published on finally withdrew
uh the paper um and then sometimes other
things happened this happened i think
just in the last week um some canadian
researchers uh made an error in the
adverse event rate of one of the
vaccines uh that has uh
myocarditis as a
adverse effect um unfortunately that it
was published on the pre-print server
the
anti-vaccination groups just pounced all
over it um and then when the error was
discovered which resulted in about a
20-fold increase of the estimate of
myocarditis it was too late
although
the the pre-print was fixed
but
you know unfortunately the information
had been disseminated
um
so
you know unfortunately there is a better
way and so i'm gonna take a little
detour i i mentioned that i was not able
to attend orientation last week i um had
uh the opportunity actually to go to
germany and actually a little side trip
into austria um some of you know
professor reinhold houcks who
had a big retirement celebration um and
he invited me to to visit and so i
turned it into a vacation
um
clearly the european countries are
handling covet a lot better and
it's it bears out in the statistics when
you look at the number
of cases and so forth
but i had to show my um vaccination card
to get into germany in the first place
now unfortunately
our
vaccination
documentation system could be better
um
and i'll get to that in a moment but not
not only did i have to show my
vaccination card to get into the country
i also had to show it to get into most
tourist venues um to eat inside
restaurants and things like that and
they also do a lot of contract tracing
and how do they do this there's actually
an app some of you may have heard of
called luca
and
you um
luca can store your verifiable
vaccine credential and it performs
contract contact tracing so for example
if you go to a big tourist site um
actually the way i had to do it was i
have the the upper picture as a sign and
i would put my phone up and capture that
qr code and i would
log in that i was visiting this
particular site
it would then actually um i'd have to
type in my cell phone number and then it
would send me a text message and then it
would ask me when i was leaving to
sign out and of course the advantage to
that is if there were any kind of
outbreak that i may have been exposed to
um
i would be able to be notified
now there in our country there's a lot
of um
maybe concern about the kind of big
brother nature of this but on the other
hand when cases occur they're quickly
detected and that then leads to another
thing that's very common in almost on
every street corner
um is um rapid testing so if you're well
not only if you're having symptoms but
also if you're um in certain um
occupations for example
um
uh my wife and i went on a food tour
and the tour guide was actually an opera
singer and um she actually
during the opera season had to get
tested daily because
singing is one way um if you're infected
with covet of spreading it
and so she had to show up each day with
a negative rapid test and so this keeps
the numbers way down and if it's
positive you quarantine
um until you're better
and so um
i
i it was an interesting experience to
see and i thought i would share with you
all there's certainly informatics
aspects of this i'm not just telling you
about my
summer vacation
but let's talk about some of the other
um areas
i i think that
we continue to do
work
um
we consider we continue to see
progress and also challenges
with machine learning and artificial
intelligence in
biomedicine
we
most of the successes in machine
learning are with
well-curated
data sets
and i actually
wrote in my blog and and actually i
participated in the bridge to ai
workshop with the nih
at where people put forth um
grand challenges and i put forth the
grand challenge it was one of 25 that
was accepted for presentation
about the need for us to have
translational
ai that we need to go beyond just having
a data set showing it works well showing
it works as well as radiologists or
whoever but actually figuring out how to
make it work in clinical settings and i
think that's the next big frontier for
ai and i hope
students looking for research projects
will think about that sort of thing
and and we still have challenges many of
the studies published are poorly
designed um in machine learning that
most of them are retrospective so um you
know we really
we know that they work well with the
data set but they don't go much beyond
that
there's a lot of other concerns now that
are bubbling up with algorithms and ai
um
as many of you know
epic the most widely used and the one
also used at ohsu has a number of
proprietary algorithms
um which
people are concerned about uh
because they're proprietary um and there
have been some studies that have shown
that they don't work well in all
settings
they've actually been shown to be
effective in some
um so we we need a better way to um
evaluate algorithms they should not be
black boxes um well i suppose all deep
learning algorithms are black boxes in
some sense but but we should be able to
know how they're trained and and what
they do and so forth um in fact our
friend peter embi who i mentioned um
earlier in the talk
came up with a new term uh it's kind of
offshoot of the term pharmacovigilance
where we need to monitor
drugs um as they're
approved and used in the healthcare
system we by the same token we need
algorithm of vigilance in that we need
to
be
vigilant and and tracking and see how
well they work and and where they fall
down around algorithms um an interesting
paper was published earlier this year
about
this is the group that includes ken
mandel and others at boston children's
about data set shifts that they call it
um so we may train an algorithm or train
a model on on a particular data set
using a particular technology with a
particular
population
and and
their things may change um
clinician behavior may change patient
behavior may change so we need to be
cognizant of these
things
and
we also need to
study them in a prospective way and this
is actually example of a good study the
study by escobar came from kaiser
permanente
they carried out a prospective cohort
study of an algorithm they added more
hospitals
and and then they measured the effect as
the algorithm was implemented the
algorithm was
open
nothing about it was proprietary and
they actually showed that
they were able to detect patients
deteriorating in the hospital earlier
and achieve better clinical outcomes so
there are ways to do this and um
hopefully we'll we'll do that another
interesting data point um a paper
published by a friend of ours from
australia that some of you know enrico
coyera
who noted that
the vast number of clinical decisions
support studies in the informatics
literature have rarely been replicated
you know moving the the clinical
decision support rule to a new
institution maybe with a new patient set
things like that
um
one bright spot is
a
growing
quantity of high quality data and
most of you are probably familiar with
the national covid cohort collaborative
which was led by our former
faculty member melissa handel who has
now moved on to the university of
colorado
and
some of our
faculty and students have taken
advantage of that data set and there's
also some other big data sets that have
come forth out of
covid
although uh some of these are expanding
well well actually the the um
the consortium for clinical
characterization uh actually comes from
the odyssey project which is a much
larger data set and likewise open safely
from the uk
so i see him in the audience so i wanted
to put out a plug for one of our
students uh
carlos
figueroa castro who
um
was looking for a capstone project for
his master's degree he's an infectious
disease physician who has an interested
in an interest in
um
non-tuberculous
mycobacterium infection so mycobacterium
is
known to um
mycobacterium tuberculosis is the famous
bacteria that causes tuberculosis but
there are other um
genus there are other species of
mycobacterium and his research interests
and so he was able to
um kind of kick the tires of the n3c
and um he's gotten a couple publications
out of it and so um and there's a
process uh one goes through to
create a data use
agreement and so
this opportunity is available to other
students faculty and so forth
this
is not new news
but um we continue to make progress in
data standards so the 21st century cures
rule
um has really
started to kind of create a
common format um for interoperability of
data
we still have a ways to go
but um we've at least now kind of agreed
up have agreed upon the format um
using the fast healthcare
interoperability resources or fire
and
hopefully this will lead to more
standardization of data so ability to
use data across
different sites to merge data sets
together and so forth
um another um
um activity of work that has been going
on in the last
um year
uh we we have recognized that that we
those of us who promote the use of the
electronic health record have
created a double-edged sword we have um
i i don't think anyone would argue that
we should go back to paper medical
records
but the systems that have been developed
and implemented not always by um those
of us in the academic informatics
community um but clearly the um
a number of the electronic health record
implementations around the u.s
have
added burden in particular documentation
burden which um burdens clinician time
and is associated with clinician burnout
and so
um a number of initiatives have been
undertaken probably the highest profile
has been the um 25x5 initiative
led by columbia and vanderbilt with
funding from the national library of
medicine
aiming to reduce documentation burden to
25 of its current level in five years
and there will be many ways that we do
that we'll build better systems we'll be
more cognizant of workflow um there will
likely be a role for machine learning we
um
for example i i think a big opportunity
is with voice
of um i always argue sometimes people
say should we get the computer out of
the exam room and i are you know we
should get the keyboard out of the exam
room but we should keep the computer
there and hopefully um and in fact there
are systems including some commercial
ones now that that capture the patient
physician interaction and generate a
note and and things like that
that will hopefully contribute
to reducing the burden
um the last thing i will mention and
then i will unshare and and open the
floor um is around certification of
informatics professionals so
um healthcare is a discipline that
has the certification of individuals
probably more for those who work in
operational
settings than say academic or research
settings
but certification is a way that that we
can recognize and verify
uh a certain level of education
experience and knowledge of an
individual and the clinical informatics
subspecialty for physicians has been
around for almost a decade now
and um and there is a process for
physicians to become board certified in
clinical informatics
and many of us are
and there's also a process to train
um future board certified physicians
such as our acgme accredited fellowship
but um physicians are not the only group
that work in operational informatics
and so amia has
been working on a certification process
this
again mostly focused on operational
health care settings although i think
it will broaden to things like public
health then perhaps research and things
like that
and this process has taken a long time
there's there's been a lot of starts and
stops um the name has changed it's
currently called the amia health
informatics certification or ahec
and it's um
actually i have this wrong here it's
actually not only for clinicians but it
includes clinicians who come from um
non-uh
physician background so nurses
pharmacist dentists but it's also meant
for people who work in public health
actually for people who are not
clinicians who who have other um formal
training and and work in informatics uh
professionally so amia
has established its health informatics
certification commission
and the
um
first
offering of the certification exam will
take place this fall
this is a little different than a lot of
physician certifications and that you
actually have to have
some
in addition to eventually you'll have to
have at least a master's degree in
informatics
there's ways now to
grandfather in with with professional
work um but even once that
grandfathering period ends
um
that there will be a period of um
uh work that one work experience that
one needs before they can be eligible to
get certified which may be in perhaps is
the sort of equivalent for uh residency
or fellowship that
physicians do
but anyways it'll be interesting to see
the uptake of this certification
people ask me
should i be certified in informatics and
i tell people that it it can't hurt it's
it um it's a credential of course um
so is a
degree or or a graduate certificate
that's also a credential as well
i think ultimately we'll come down to
those who hire
people who work in informatics we do see
among physicians in informatics now that
that board certification
it's not an absolute
but it is something
as
physicians who are
becoming things like chief medical
information officer and so forth that um
there is uh
certification that's required or that
many people who hire want to see happen
and we'll see what happens in terms of
um
a hick and and others who work in
informatics besides physicians
so i'm going to stop at this point
and stop my sharing
and um i i see that there's been um
plenty of conversation going on in the
chat
um i will um
um let's see
um
maybe
well actually let me just stop and open
the floor if anyone wants to unmute and
while you're doing that i will look
through the
um
um
uh
chat and see if there's anything of
interest there
so um
what did i forget what else should i
have mentioned
feel free to unmute and speak up
okay well i will i will look through the
chat i do see that um
[Music]
interesting about germany i was actually
not aware of that but um
you know certainly
one of the reasons for trying to
identify
people are those who are in group
settings who may infect others and and
it's a challenge with children um
we know that children generally tend to
do well after covet infection though a
small
fraction of them do not
and then they also have the potential to
to
infect others in their families or
communities and so forth
um
yes i see that kate
was elected as a fellow of amia
congratulations
um
and um i see that some people are
talking about going to the amia meeting
i'm glad that we will have some
representation there um i will be there
too
um let's see what else do we have um i
see other um
comments about uh infectious disease
tracing which probably some of you are
more expert than i am
um
homer ass will
it also requires logical reasoning will
that happen in the u.s um
[Music]
hard to say
um
uh
uh sarah has asked about yeah who will
be at amy i know that um uh some of our
trainees will be there
um
and um
and
yeah so um let's see um uh italia has
asked about um ted
um ted also has uh left um uh ohsu
um ted um
was a um is still very uh important
contributor to the field um
decided to follow his interests um into
um uh industry we are obviously working
on finding
replacements um to for teaching the
courses that he teaches he was a very
prolific
teacher and uh one who's not
replaced easily
so
we are working on that
and
oh i should also
note
someone reminded me
that
one of our phd students rose gwett
has
won an award
and
just
see where i can find it here
um
i i i um actually if she wants to speak
up she can't she won a small grant uh to
uh build on her uh work in um
um developing
patient
decision aids for
questions about
contraception and so forth so
thank you rose from the society of
family planning
um and again if anyone else wants me to
mention
um
anything else that is important to be
mentioned you can
you can
chat me
privately or
publicly putting it into the chat
anything else that i have forgot to
mention
[Music]
this this is one of the downsides about
um
video conferencing is that
the silence
but obviously uh many of you are uh uh
typing in ah yes uh someone else
um
uh another award um that um dodge in one
of our clinical informatics uh fellows
she's been awarded a fellowship in
diagnostic excellence from the society
to improve diagnosis and medicine and
that complements her uh clinical
informatics fellowship and she's doing
that with a group of people by the way
if you all followed our twitter feed you
would have known about both of those
awards that's where i'm actually going
to find information about them into the
ohsu informatics twitter feed which
everyone should follow and contribute to
um
great thank you rose for publishing the
url and maybe
um
i think um uh das we actually um
see where's
here we go
see
and of course it goes without saying
that
you know faculty have continued to be
awarded grants
and so forth um
steve bedrick and myself
awarded an r01 from nlm
i know that david door has received a
number of
grants funded
karen eden
it's not a new grant but she's actually
going to be featured by the agency for
healthcare research and quality
for her grant um yes and the work that
vishnu and jeff
uh do
also funded by ahrq
so um
um nicole of course her uh recent r21
um
well good we um obviously we need a
better system for um publicizing i i
mean i think twitter is actually um a
nice way to do it and
um
uh a number of the other uh informatics
programs like like we do um
uh use twitter to get the word out um it
twitter's great for for you know just
sending out a url so and so got a new
grant
and of course virginia mentioning that
our graduates are doing well in in
getting jobs and
making good salaries which we recognize
is important
and
for the
trainees
the
you should take advantage of virginia's
knowledge and expertise i don't know
that anyone knows any more about the
informatics job market than virginia and
we're
it's great for us to have her
and to be available to
students and and others
um okay um i guess maybe we'll be seeing
uh
uh
um jeff
jeff gold and and vishnu and court
garrison uh in ohsu now
today
okay
well
um
on that note
we're just about at the hour anyways
um
maybe someday again we will have
these uh conferences back in the big
theater and maybe we'll even have pizza
um but um
i i have a feeling that those big
conferences will be among the last
things to return
to to normal
but um
anyways um
uh for those who are eligible to get
boosters i i hope you'll do so um i hope
that we will
uh be able to
um
get back to some semblance of of of
being together i was hoping to do more
of it this summer but then delta came
and and that kind of put the kibosh on
on some of that bill what's the latest
on um
going back to campus
um
we are still in um modified operations
until
delta is under control
the the good news is that we've hit the
peak in oregon
those of you probably like myself who
either follow the connie sealy emails or
also
again on twitter
every day
ohsu news publishes a graphic
showing the number of cases in the
hospital number of cases number of
patients on ventilators and in the icu
and they break them out
by vaccinated and unvaccinated and you
see that
almost
none of the
ventilator and icu patients are
unvaccinated there unfortunately are a
small number of breakthrough cases
um
i i've we're on modified operations
through the end of the fall quarter
i think that once the numbers really um
unquestionably start to come back down i
mean remember in the summer we in like
early july we were down to like three
covet patients in the hospital you know
we
went back up to about 50 or 60. i think
we're down in the 40s now
so um
hopefully um
[Music]
we'll we'll be returning at some point
or have the ability to return
okay well um
i see it i see we're at the hour so i
want to thank everyone for coming today
i want to encourage everyone to consider
talking in this conference let us hear
about your great work
for faculty
you might find students who want to
expand upon your great work
and
also participate in our
various forms of social media
okay well have a good day everyone and
um
see you all soon bye-bye